i know you're a christian i'm so sorry
man i am now
[Laughter]
i was atheist when i walked through the
door but after watching you do your
marcel marso mime show over there
i'm ready to walk through a wall and
punch casper in the [ __ ]
so you don't like it when i do that just
a lot no but don't look like you're it's
like
no it's it's like you're watching that
what's that one
christopher nolan movie that's really
with the with matthew mcconaughey is in
it interstellar
like you're watching interstellar like i
like to explain myself how about i'm
watching in your cellar
oh yeah yeah yeah
i like to explain yeah go ahead so i'm
jerking off and you're like looking at
me like that no it's like this you know
when you're when you're ready to go
i'm sorry man
it looks like you have a piece of celery
in your hand
yeah like at least go like this yeah
yeah yeah you're like like all right
now it looks like you're bouncing a
koala
yeah
yeah yes i genuinely like like that's
that's my kink i think i like watching
dudes and their most like what i think
is the blankest moment in their minds
that they'll ever be which is coming i
don't think there's a thought between
those eyes when dudes come and i have a
kink for that i'm like look how [ __ ]
stupid he looks right now and i like it
it turns me on did you say that like you
ever said look how stupid you look right
now and i don't mean it that he's stupid
but really like when you're coming
like biologi there's nothing going on in
your head whoa wait a minute now
what do you mean wait a minute that's
not true for you no
i think a philosophical thing like yeah
like sartre
you know i mean like that the play no
exit
right right right
you're right and
hell is people
right is that the last line of no exit
hell is other people yeah that's what
i'm thinking dark [ __ ] okay yeah i mean
what is dixie what do girls think of
when they're having their
they go same thing nothing what do you
think of harlan
when i finally do the big o do one
i'll let you know
i haven't done it yet
virgin
saving myself for the mortician
hopefully he can get me one just as my
eyes finally
yeah
let me ask you something
no thanks i'm busy
what
but you've never masturbated whoa guys
[Laughter]
what name
left ass cheek is going on here
[Laughter]
sorry dude
i thought i could cross certain lines
and barriers bro i don't know that see
if we were out alone just having donuts
and windchills
i wouldn't let you ask me that i don't
know right right right you can ask it
but there's a lot of stuff i will never
talk about is sex
no just a lot there's a lot of topics
like what what what won't you talk about
i won't talk about my marriage my old
marriage ah there's there's just things
that are sacred things you know
things are
sacred but but that's what's interesting
about you guys you guys are so open it
blows my mind we're learning that things
need to be safe it's not good because
it's at a cost for sure it isn't that's
why i keep stuff in but i'm also jealous
i'll be honest i get jealous of people
that can just be so blatantly wide open
yeah because in a way it's very
freeing it's very releasing because
you're not putting up any psychological
walls or barriers like
it blows my mind and i'm jealous of it
but i'm also like freaked by it but
that's why watching this i feel like
[ __ ] the flat screen this is the
best netflix show i've ever seen right
now yeah yeah but you know we're not
together anymore
oh yeah we're not
oh
sorry yeah
so why can't we can we do it now or
do you can do what expose ourselves yeah
yeah no you you are i mean holy [ __ ]
yeah i'm sorry but i think that maybe
that was the root of some of our
problems do you think